Get some calls on. Hi, this is Joel with the Taproot Therapy Therapy Collective podcast, Discover He'll Grow. And I'm here today with MJ Dennis from Austin, Texas. And she's a provider that I trained with when I did emotional transformation therapy. She was incredibly helpful. She did a lot of my consultations. And we've kind of kept in touch.
欢迎收听。你好，我是Taproot Therapy Therapy Collective播客的乔尔，欢迎收听《发现治愈与成长》。今天我邀请到了来自德克萨斯州奥斯汀的MJ·丹尼斯。她是我在学习情绪转化疗法（ETT）时的培训导师。她给予了我极大的帮助，负责了我很多咨询工作。我们一直保持着联系。
And she was just a really welcoming presence in the emotional transformation community to kind of welcome me in. want to make it sound like it's a cult, but it is a lot to learn. And there was like so much that the technical bit and a lot of things about, you know, how you're going to grow into these things that you are always so warm and open and encouraging. So I really appreciate that because it's been for my practice a lot now. And I'll let you talk about kind of your practice and we can have a conversation about ETT today and some of the some of the stuff that on its, on its face sounds kind of wild, you know, but but really is a scientific pursuit.
她在情绪转化社区中一直是一个非常热情的人，欢迎我的加入。我不想让它听起来像个邪教，但确实有很多东西要学。关于技术细节，以及你如何成长为一名治疗师，有很多内容，而你总是那么温暖、开放和鼓励。我真的很感激，因为这对我的执业帮助很大。接下来我想让你谈谈你的执业经历，我们可以聊聊ETT，以及其中一些乍听起来很疯狂，但实际上是科学探索的内容。
there. Hey, Joel. Thank you for saying that. I'm glad I did make you feel warm and welcome. ETT, emotional transformation therapy, was not something I saw coming, but once I learned how to do it, it transformed my practice. And so I am an LPC, a licensed professional counselor, and an LMFT, a licensed marriage and family therapist right outside of Austin, Texas, and Sam Marcus. I began, I started my counseling journey. I became a counselor in 2012 and became certified as a sex therapist through ASET.
你好，乔尔。谢谢你这么说。很高兴我能让你感到温暖和受欢迎。ETT（情绪转化疗法）并不是我预料之中的事，但一旦我学会了它，它就彻底改变了我的执业方式。我是一名LPC（持证专业咨询师）和LMFT（持证婚姻与家庭治疗师），在德克萨斯州奥斯汀郊外执业。我是在2012年开始我的咨询生涯的，并获得了ASET认证的性治疗师资格。
And then after working at Crossroads Counseling Associates, we were affiliated with the Affair Recovery Center. And so working with. infidelity experts, I leaned into a lot of training in betrayal trauma recovery, so I'm an absent certified partner trauma specialist as well. I learned about being a sex therapist, I learned about out-of-control sexual behaviors. Through Sash, I learned about sex addiction. I really leaned into training outside of grad school. But I recognized as a I was working with clients, talk therapy is wonderful and it's effective, but it only gets so far. And so I decided to learn some brain-based interventions.
在Crossroads Counseling Associates工作后，我们与Affair Recovery Center建立了合作关系。因此，在与不忠行为专家合作的过程中，我深入学习了背叛创伤恢复，我也是一名ABS认证的伴侣创伤专家。我学习了如何成为一名性治疗师，了解了失控的性行为。通过SASH，我学习了性成瘾。我确实在研究生院之外进行了大量的培训。但我意识到，在与客户合作时，谈话疗法虽然很棒且有效，但它有局限性。所以我决定学习一些基于大脑的干预措施。
I knew that I needed something more to help my clients than talk therapy. So I learned how to do EMDR and eye movement, desensitization, reprocessing. I thought EMDR was amazing. And it was really, really helpful and a good fit for some of my clients. Some of my clients, it was not a good fit. And so I was looking for something better. Did you notice a three line between that? Because I'd like to look for the kind of a diagram of our journey.
我知道我需要比谈话疗法更能帮助客户的东西。所以我学习了EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）。我觉得EMDR很棒，对我的某些客户确实非常有帮助，非常适合。但对另一些客户来说，它并不适用。所以我一直在寻找更好的方法。你注意到这中间的三条线了吗？因为我想找一张我们旅程的图表。
It sounded like we kind of were on similar trajectories. And when I got trained in EMDR, I thought it was just kind of a purple hat therapy that maybe would distract people or something. And it didn't do much for me. And then I started noticing like, whoa, like for 2030, percent of people there is a very strong neurological effect. But within two weeks, I was like, this does not work for the reason that they say it works. Like, I don't see that bilateral synchronization thing. I mean, I think Francine Shapiro's guesses were great for 1984. I just think that we've got 30 more years of neuroscience. And I started looking for like, who's this helping,
听起来我们似乎走在相似的轨道上。当我接受EMDR培训时，我以为它只是一种“紫帽子疗法”，可能只是分散人们的注意力之类的。它对我没起多大作用。后来我开始注意到，哇，对于20%到30%的人来说，它有非常强的神经学效应。但在两周内，我就觉得，它起作用的原因并不是他们所说的那样。我不认为存在那种双侧同步现象。我认为弗朗辛·夏皮罗在1984年的猜测很棒，但我只是觉得我们已经有了30年的神经科学积累。我开始寻找：它对谁有帮助，
who's this not helping? And I noticed that dissociative patients would respond really strongly to it, but it wasn't always the best for them because they tended to be layers where you would treat this thing they thought was the problem and then something else would come up and they would decompensate and then you'd treat that and it was like okay well we're going through a well so you know you take one thing off the top the next thing floats up eventually you're going to run out of stuff but the process was pretty messy so they tended to like it whereas I was like you don't realize what it's really going to be like to stir up eight months of work in a session you know I don't know I'm just wondering if you saw three lines of who it helped who it
对谁没有帮助？我注意到解离型患者对它的反应非常强烈，但这并不总是最适合他们的，因为他们往往有多个层面，你治疗了他们认为的问题，然后又会出现别的问题，他们会失代偿，然后你再去治疗那个，就像在挖一口井。你从上面拿走一样东西，下一件东西就会浮上来，最终你会把东西清理完，但过程非常混乱。他们往往喜欢它，而我当时想，你根本不知道在一次治疗中搅动八个月的工作会是什么样子。我不知道，我只是想知道你是否看到了它对谁有帮助，对谁
didn't what you liked about it what you didn't because I'm EMDR trained I haven't done it for probably seven years. Brain spotting almost entirely replaced and ETT expanded that so I was just curious if you made observations at that time. I like you. I don't do EMDR anymore.
没有帮助，你喜欢它什么，不喜欢它什么，因为我受过EMDR培训，但我已经大概七年没做过了。脑点疗法（Brainspotting）几乎完全取代了它，而ETT则扩展了它，所以我很好奇你当时是否有过观察。我和你一样，我也不再做EMDR了。
I don't need to. ETT is just more effective and efficient and I can treat a wider variety of conditions that impact people. my lens, Joel, is through safety, being in this field of sex therapy in conjunction with
我不需要了。ETT更有效、更高效，而且我可以治疗影响人们的更广泛的疾病。乔尔，我的视角是通过安全感，因为我身处性治疗领域，结合
betrayal trauma and infidelity. I often think through a safety lens. People come in so traumatized and grief-stricken. And when they've experienced betrayal, you know, the world doesn't feel safe. So when I'm doing therapy and using ETT, I like it more than EMDR because my brain says, I can keep my client safe. Meaning, when they were doing EMDR, it was almost like being on a train for some people. Memories would wash by people. And even though we can do some containment, I felt like I couldn't really control or keep them safe and focused during the process. That was my experience. That brain spotting became the surgical tool to go all the way through one thing.
背叛创伤和不忠问题。我经常通过安全的视角来思考。人们进来时带着巨大的创伤和悲伤。当他们经历过背叛时，世界感觉不再安全。所以当我在做治疗并使用ETT时，我比EMDR更喜欢它，因为我的大脑告诉我，我可以保证客户的安全。意思是，当他们做EMDR时，对某些人来说就像坐在一列火车上。记忆会像潮水般涌过。尽管我们可以做一些控制，但我感觉在过程中我无法真正控制或保证他们的安全和专注。这就是我的体验。脑点疗法成为了彻底解决一件事的手术工具。
Whereas when we were concentrating on an emotion and doing the things, they're like, now I'm on heroin, now I'm in the flop house, now I'm hiding out in Vegas. Now I'm doing this. Now I'm doing this. And they're confused.
而当我们专注于某种情绪并做这些事情时，他们会说，现在我在吸海洛因，现在我在廉价旅馆，现在我躲在拉斯维加斯。现在我在做这个。现在我在做那个。他们感到困惑。
But it really is like, you know, you're on this train of memory, everything related to that. Which the web, right? It goes from one memory to another. Yep. I think that's a riskier way to get there.
但这确实就像你说的，你处于记忆的列车上，所有相关的一切都在那里。也就是网络，对吧？它从一个记忆连接到另一个记忆。是的。我认为这是一种风险更高的方法。
I mean, it did work for the people who got treatment that way. A lot of those patients have now come back and brain spotting the ETT, I think, took them deeper into things that we thought we were done with. Yes, yes. I still can offer EMDR, but once my clients experience ETT, that's, they find it a better fit for them. And so people don't ask for EMDR. I've had one lady in the last eight years asked me to do MDR.
我的意思是，对于那些以这种方式接受治疗的人来说，它确实有效。很多这样的患者现在又回来了，脑点疗法和ETT，我认为带他们深入到了我们以为已经解决的事情中。是的，是的。我仍然可以提供EMDR，但一旦我的客户体验了ETT，他们就会发现它更适合他们。所以人们不会要求做EMDR。在过去八年里，只有一位女士要求我做EMDR。
So I met her where she was. With ETT, what ended up happening, I worked with a gentleman. I worked with a gentleman Rick Reynolds, who gets, he does all the trainings. He tries to stay really cutting edge. And he met Dr. Stephen Bosquez. And Dr. Vasquez had moved from Dallas to Austin. And it was actually practicing around the corner from our practice. And Rick did some training with him.
所以我满足了她的需求。关于ETT，最终发生的事情是，我与一位绅士合作。我与一位名叫里克·雷诺兹的绅士合作，他参加了所有的培训。他总是试图保持在最前沿。他遇到了斯蒂芬·瓦斯奎兹博士。瓦斯奎兹博士从达拉斯搬到了奥斯汀。他实际上就在我们诊所的拐角处执业。里克接受了他的一些培训。
And Rick and I at that point, we were on either side of a wall. Our offices were next to each other. And so as we would walk our clients to the waiting room, he'd say, MJ, I have a client with depression. And I did ETT, and the depression is gone. And I remember just kind of patting him on the shoulder and saying, sure, Rick. And I was very skeptical.
当时我和里克就在一堵墙的两边。我们的办公室挨在一起。所以当我们把客户带到候诊室时，他会说：“MJ，我有一个抑郁症客户。我用了ETT，抑郁症消失了。”我记得我只是拍了拍他的肩膀说：“当然了，里克。”我当时非常怀疑。
And how can, how can that be? And then we would walk out and go to the waiting room and he'd say, MJ, have a client with anxiety. And I did ETT. And the anxiety is gone. Sure, Rick. And then story after Joel of working with somebody using ETT to help their OCD intrusive and ruminating thoughts stop and their compulsive behaviors remit. We talked about using ETT for ADHD presentations, for grief, for trauma. The list was endless. And at some point, I was so skeptical, but I trust Rick and he kept having these stories. So one day, my 8 a.m. client canceled and his 8 a.m. client canceled.
这怎么可能呢？然后我们会走出去到候诊室，他又会说：“MJ，我有一个焦虑症客户。我用了ETT，焦虑症消失了。”“当然了，里克。”然后，乔尔，一个接一个的故事，关于使用ETT帮助他们的强迫症侵入性思维和反刍思维停止，以及强迫行为缓解。我们谈到了使用ETT治疗多动症、悲伤、创伤。名单无穷无尽。在某个时刻，我虽然非常怀疑，但我信任里克，而且他不断有这些故事。所以有一天，我的8点钟客户取消了，他的8点钟客户也取消了。
and he invited me to do an ETT session with him. And I jumped on that. Yes. At that time, Joel, so he said, MJ, think of something. When you think of it that you have a lot of distress or emotions about. Not that time something had happened with one of my sons. And as I was sitting in Rick's office, he stood in front of me with some sticks that had color on the end and he said mj i want you to talk about your boy and talk about this
他邀请我和他一起做一次ETT疗程。我立刻答应了。是的。当时，乔尔，他说：“MJ，想一件事情。当你想到它时，你会感到非常痛苦或有强烈的情绪。”当时我其中一个儿子发生了一些事情。当我坐在里克的办公室里时，他拿着一些末端有颜色的棍子站在我面前，他说：“MJ，我想让你谈谈你的儿子，谈谈这件事，
experience this thing that's happening in your lives and look at the sticks with the color at the end and i'm going to move them and i want you to follow them with your eyes and joel i thought he had lost his mind about what is he talking about but i did i talked about the experience i cried i was very, very distressed. And as I followed with my eyes and I followed the sticks, I could feel my emotions changing. He switched out the different colors a few times. I could feel my stress getting lighter. My, the tears stopped and he then he moved me over and sat me from the physical changes.
谈谈你们生活中正在发生的这件事，看着那些末端有颜色的棍子，我会移动它们，我希望你用眼睛跟着它们。”乔尔，我当时以为他疯了，他在说什么？但我照做了，我谈论了那次经历，我哭了，我非常、非常痛苦。当我用眼睛跟着棍子移动时，我能感觉到我的情绪在改变。他换了几次不同的颜色。我能感觉到我的压力变轻了。我的眼泪停止了，然后他让我坐下来，从身体层面感受变化。
They're always almost what people notice before the emotional change. It blooms into the. Well, right. The tears stopped. So my sadness was lightning, and I had all kinds of fear and sadness and mama bear guilt and shame and how do I protect my child and how did these things happen or going through my mind, distressing thoughts. When he sat me in front of the ETT chart, the spectral chart, it, as you know, it has colors, strips of colors on. And I remember Rick saying, if the colors change in any way, that means you're dissociating and tell me right away. Again, Joel, I really, Rick, the colors, this is a poster.
这些总是人们在情绪变化之前最先注意到的。它会绽放成……嗯，对吧。眼泪停止了。所以我的悲伤减轻了，我心中充满了各种恐惧、悲伤、母亲的内疚和羞耻，以及我该如何保护我的孩子，这些事情是怎么发生的，或者在我脑海中闪过的痛苦想法。当他让我坐在ETT图表（光谱图）前时，如你所知，它上面有色带。我记得里克说：“如果颜色有任何变化，那就意味着你在解离，马上告诉我。”再次，乔尔，我真的……里克，这些颜色，这只是一张海报。
How are the colors going to change? But okay. So as he instructed me where to look, talk about my son and this experience, the color expanded. I was looking at green and the color expanded. He said, you're dissociating. Close your eyes. And then he had me do some thinking and answer a sensory question. I opened my eyes and the color was back.
颜色怎么会变呢？但好吧。当他指导我看向哪里，谈论我的儿子和这次经历时，颜色扩大了。我看着绿色，颜色扩大了。他说：“你在解离。闭上眼睛。”然后他让我做了一些思考，并回答了一个感官问题。我睁开眼睛，颜色又回来了。
And I didn't know what happened, but that was weird. And then look at this color. Talk about it again. The color disappeared. He said, you're dissociating. Close your eyes. He got me back online, right? Got me connected to myself.
我不知道发生了什么，但这很奇怪。然后看这个颜色。再谈谈它。颜色消失了。他说：“你在解离。闭上眼睛。”他让我恢复了状态，对吧？让我重新与自己连接。
And then after looking at a few colors, he suddenly said, okay, MJ, that's, it, you're done. And what do you mean I'm done? And he literally, Joel, he went like this, have a nice day. And I went back to my office and it had been like 23 minutes. And when I thought about what was happening with my son, I mean, neutral, my distress was reduced. My body, my nervous system felt calm. And even though I had no idea what had just happened, I knew I had to get trained in because he was on to something. He experienced something profound. Yeah, I won't talk to people about the science until they sit down.
然后看了几种颜色后，他突然说：“好了，MJ，就这样，你完成了。”“你是什么意思，我完成了？”他真的，乔尔，他做了个手势，说：“祝你今天愉快。”我回到办公室，大概只用了23分钟。当我想到我儿子发生的事情时，我的情绪变得中性了，痛苦减轻了。我的身体，我的神经系统感到平静。尽管我不知道刚才发生了什么，但我知道我必须接受培训，因为他确实掌握了一些东西。你体验到了深刻的东西。是的，在人们坐下来之前，我不会和他们谈论科学。
I'm like, look, if you're going to sit down, it's couch for five minutes. I can show you something that you can't explain. But if I start talking about the science, you're just going to think of crazy. And then once they try it, they're like, wait, but how could that? And I'm like, well, because the optic nerve doesn't go directly to acipital. It wraps around the brainstem. And you feel 90% of what you're seeing before you actually see it. and bubble, you know, but if you start trying to front load that, you're, you're just going to
我说：“听着，如果你愿意坐下来，在沙发上待五分钟，我可以给你展示一些你无法解释的东西。但如果我开始谈论科学，你只会觉得我疯了。”然后一旦他们尝试了，他们会说：“等等，这怎么可能？”我说：“嗯，因为视神经不是直接通向枕叶的。它绕过脑干。在你真正看到它之前，你已经感受到了你所看到的90%的内容。”等等，你知道的，但如果你一开始就试图灌输这些，你只会
scare everybody away. But there is a really, there is an effect where people are like, you know, they kind of need to blink and test it. And then they're like, I can't, I can't explain this. I can't talk my way out of this. It's replicating consistently, you know. Yes. I have that same experience where I'll try to give someone a scientific explanation because
把所有人都吓跑。但确实有一种效果，人们会觉得，你知道，他们需要眨眨眼，测试一下。然后他们会说：“我无法解释这个。我无法用言语来解释。它在持续地复制，你知道的。”是的。我有同样的经历，我会试图给某人一个科学的解释，因为
we humans, as you know, we, we, we, like that. like to understand when we want to understand. So one way I explain ETT, I'll say emotional transformation therapy is a form of psychotherapy that integrates the use of light and color. So while a person talks about a topic, there's a verbalization component and they feel their emotions, There's the emotional component while using visual eye stimulation. Those are the wavelengths of light. How a person feels emotionally and physically changes.
我们人类，如你所知，我们喜欢理解，当我们想要理解的时候。所以我解释ETT的一种方式是，我会说情绪转化疗法是一种整合了光和颜色使用的心理治疗形式。当一个人谈论一个话题时，有一个语言表达部分，他们会感受到自己的情绪，这是情绪部分，同时使用视觉眼动刺激。那些是光的波长。一个人在情绪和身体上的感受会发生改变。
Let's be short blurb. So let's back up just a little bit. And Dr. Vasquez, who is going to be on here later, hopefully that will be the episode that follows this one. You know, he, most therapy, modalities come about when there's somebody in the I'd like to go a little bit back in his story and in yours like you know they come about where somebody says like I'm kind of tired of talking about the ego and the id what if there's five parts of self and then the patient says oh yeah I have an inner critic or pusher and then they write down well you should engage you know and it comes from that kind of clinical experimentation but you know Vasquez is a very educated guy I mean I think he's got like four degrees or something but he basically read research and it didn't come about that way. It was a neurological thing where he read all these ways the brain worked and was like, well, if it does this, would this do something to emotion, you know, based on other people's data? And, you know, in his book, I think he says he built six devices or eight devices or something.
让我们简短一点。让我们稍微回顾一下。瓦斯奎兹博士，希望他能出现在下一集节目中。你知道，大多数治疗流派都是在有人……我想稍微回顾一下他的故事和你的故事，你知道，它们产生于有人说：“我有点厌倦谈论自我和本我了，如果自我有五个部分呢？”然后患者说：“哦，是的，我有一个内在批评者或推动者。”然后他们写下：“嗯，你应该参与其中。”它来自那种临床实验。但你知道，瓦斯奎兹是一个受过高等教育的人，我想他有四个学位之类的，但他基本上是阅读了研究报告，它不是那样产生的。这是一个神经学上的事情，他阅读了所有大脑运作的方式，然后想：“嗯，如果它这样做，这会对情绪产生影响吗？”你知道，基于其他人的数据？而且，你知道，在他的书中，我想他说他制造了六个或八个设备之类的。
And then basically four of them worked. And, you know, he was willing to get outside of the box. He had the creativity and the openness to say, well, what if, you know, I kind of like color and light. What if that does something? But he also had, and not be kind of afraid of that, he has a scary space, but he also had the scientific, you know, credulousness to say, these don't work. These aren't doing anything. When you shine light through skin, it tends to not work unless it's red. And then it just is affecting mitochondria and muscles, it's not really affecting the brain as much. You know, and so the four devices that he built based on those theoretical maps are really effective. And they've become the kind of modules that ETT is. But you had told me, I think, at one of the trainings that you'd seen him present a lot of the time and that you were kind of outraged about the absurdity of it you know that you before you actually came into ETT you were you're having the same kind of response that I was having of like you know this is crazy you know this this is this all the chroma therapies in the 70s were
然后基本上其中四个起作用了。而且，你知道，他愿意跳出框框。他有创造力和开放性去说：“嗯，如果我喜欢颜色和光呢？如果那能起作用呢？”但他也有，并且不害怕这一点，他有一个可怕的空间，但他也有科学的严谨性去说：“这些不起作用。这些什么都没做。当你把光穿过皮肤时，除非是红光，否则它往往不起作用。而那只是影响线粒体和肌肉，它并没有真正影响大脑。”你知道，所以他基于那些理论图谱制造的四个设备确实非常有效。它们已经成为了ETT的模块。但你曾在一次培训中告诉我，你看到他展示过很多次，而且你对它的荒谬性感到愤怒，你知道，在你真正进入ETT之前，你有着和我一样的反应，觉得“这太疯狂了”，你知道，这……70年代所有的色光疗法都是
scam this is just you know yeah you know yeah I met a another counselor uh doctor Annie Curlin she practices in California and I met Annie at a conference And she said, you know, MJ really should check out this ETT emotional transformation therapy. I do this. It uses light and color and it's amazing. And it transforms how people feel very quickly. And it is replicable and it's effective. And I blew her off.
骗局，这只是……是的，你知道，是的，我遇到了另一位咨询师，安妮·柯林博士，她在加利福尼亚执业，我在一次会议上遇到了安妮。她说：“你知道，MJ，你真的应该看看这个ETT情绪转化疗法。我做这个。它使用光和颜色，非常神奇。它能非常快地改变人们的感受。它是可复制的，而且非常有效。”我拒绝了她。
I just, when I heard light and color, I thought, no, nope. A serious person. I do serious therapy. Yeah. no not doing that um and then i ran into her again a couple of years later and she said did you get trained in et t yet and no i did not and she said she pushed me again really consider this well it wasn't until rick learned et t and i had that experience at crossroads and i had even um seeing Dr. Vasquez do a demo at one of those conferences along the way when I was training.
我只是，当我听到光和颜色时，我想：“不，不行。我是个严肃的人。我做严肃的治疗。”是的，不，我不做那个。然后几年后我又遇到了她，她说：“你接受ETT培训了吗？”“没有，我没有。”她说，她再次催促我：“真的考虑一下。”嗯，直到里克学习了ETT，我在Crossroads有了那次经历，甚至在培训过程中，我在那些会议上看到瓦斯奎兹博士做过演示。
It was a sash conference and I was training and how to be a sex therapist and do help people with sexual issues and Dr. Vasquez presented and he did a light box demonstration where he had somebody with distress, who was just another therapist in the room, sit in front of the device and he had them talk about their distress. They were in touch with their emotions. He showed light and color into their eyes, colors that matched their emotions, and the person changed. And I remember thinking, this is the setup. They staged this. I absolutely couldn't believe that transformation could happen that quickly. So the people see things on the light box sometimes.
那是在一次SASH会议上，我正在接受培训，学习如何成为一名性治疗师并帮助人们解决性问题，瓦斯奎兹博士做了演讲，他做了一个灯箱演示，他让房间里的另一位治疗师，一个有痛苦的人，坐在设备前，他让他们谈论他们的痛苦。他们与自己的情绪保持联系。他将光和颜色射入他们的眼睛，与他们的情绪相匹配的颜色，那个人就改变了。我记得当时想：“这是个圈套。他们安排好的。”我绝对无法相信这种转变能发生得那么快。所以人们有时会在灯箱上看到东西。
I mean, they'll experience, you're just looking at a color screen and a flicker rate, but people, I didn't get that in the training, but a lot of other people did, and you all kind of prepared us for it. I think someone had seen who was processing grief of a dog, like a dog paw come out of the screen and stuff. The first time my oldest son did ETT using the light device. when he came home I said you know how was it I didn't ask him
我的意思是，他们会体验到，你只是看着一个彩色屏幕和闪烁频率，但人们……我在培训中没有得到那个，但很多人得到了，你们都为我们做了准备。我想有人在处理失去狗的悲伤时，看到像狗爪子一样的东西从屏幕里伸出来。我大儿子第一次使用ETT灯光设备时，
the content I just was curious how the ETT went for him and he said mom I saw the death star turning so he saw a shift turning in the I don't know what he was processing but his brain did create an image but it helped him
当他回家时，我说：“你知道，感觉怎么样？”我没有问他
and he was probably 19 years old at the time he experienced his first to ETT. So even that young. You had seen Vascus present a couple times and kind of been like just blown it off as this is a wild thing which is just I want to introduce that to since you know now you're a trainer of ETT that's kind of doing the top level stuff. Well and and I want to say this even now. So you know I went I did get trained in all the classes and I
内容，我只是好奇ETT对他来说怎么样，他说：“妈妈，我看到死星在转动。”所以他看到了一个转动的转变，我不知道他在处理什么，但他的大脑确实创造了一个图像，但这对他有帮助。
ETT was so effective, I could replicate it. I did my ETT level one training, Friday, Saturday, Sunday. I started using it Monday. I turned right around and started using it right away. And I've now done over 3,100 ETT sessions now and keep a track of them. And they work, like this works. So I went through the classes again to become a trainer. And now I've been going around the country and
他当时大概19岁，经历了第一次ETT。所以即使那么年轻。你曾见过瓦斯奎兹展示过几次，并把它当作一件疯狂的事情而不予理会，这只是……我想介绍一下，因为你知道，现在你是一名ETT培训师，正在做顶级的工作。嗯，我想说，即使是现在。所以，你知道，我确实参加了所有的课程，而且我
training therapists all across the country. I'd love to before the end of my career have ETP therapists in all 50 states. And even when I'm demoing, Joel, when I'm teaching a class with Dr. Voskis, sometimes he'll let me co-teach with him. The transformation happens so quickly. Even now, I'm blown away, and I have disbelief. Like, I can't work so fast. I just was in Portland.
ETT太有效了，我可以复制它。我周五、周六、周日完成了ETT一级培训。我周一就开始用了。我立刻转过身就开始使用它。我现在已经做了超过3100次ETT疗程，并记录了它们。它们确实有效，这真的有效。所以我又参加了课程成为一名培训师。现在我一直在全国各地
I just trained some therapists in Portland. And there was a counselor who was in the training, and she let me demo the light device. Her topic was, we do sentence starter sometimes. So the sentence starter was, when I think about the dark. Now, she had, she said her whole life, she had been afraid of the dark. and so here she was in her 30s still afraid of the dark and it was impacting her functioning and so that was her sentenced when I think about being afraid of the dark or when I think about the dark and fear came up and she experienced distress in her body it was like a bell curve
培训治疗师。我希望在职业生涯结束前，能在所有50个州都有ETT治疗师。即使在演示时，乔尔，当我和瓦斯奎兹博士一起教课时，有时他会让我和他一起合教。转变发生得太快了。即使是现在，我也感到震惊，我甚至有怀疑。就像，我无法工作得那么快。我刚在波特兰。
and as we use the light dyes this happened very quickly her brain remembered when she was four and she experienced an earthquake and she was with her family and in an apartment building and it was the middle of the night and everything shook and the TV fell off the wall and her mom grabbed her hand and she and her siblings and her parents ran out of the apartment building right the ground was shaking she was four she realized right her brain connected this memory her fear of the dark started with that memory she had no conscious connection to when it began. But in that instant, as I showed her shades of dark red, that far red for shock and loss and move to yellow to help with the fear and overwhelm, her fear went
我刚在波特兰培训了一些治疗师。培训中有一位咨询师，她让我演示灯光设备。她的主题是，我们有时会做句子开头练习。所以句子开头是：“当我想到黑暗时。”现在，她说她一生都害怕黑暗。所以她30多岁了仍然害怕黑暗，这影响了她的功能，所以这就是她的句子：“当我想到害怕黑暗时”或者“当我想到黑暗时”，恐惧感就出现了，她在身体上感到了痛苦，就像一条钟形曲线。
away. And here she is in a training. She's a therapist. And she said, I'm not afraid anymore. And so we even thought about the last time she had been afraid of the dark, like kind of checking it out. We did a future when you think about being in the dark tonight, her fear was gone. And she said, she felt joy. And she said, I can't believe I'm even saying this. I feel joy. I'm kind of excited. It's going to get dark tonight.
当我们使用灯光设备时，这发生得非常快，她的大脑记起了她四岁时经历了一场地震，她和家人在公寓楼里，那是半夜，一切都在摇晃，电视从墙上掉下来，她妈妈抓住她的手，她和她的兄弟姐妹以及父母跑出了公寓楼，对吧？地面在摇晃，她当时四岁，她意识到，对吧？她的大脑连接了这个记忆，她对黑暗的恐惧始于那个记忆，她对它何时开始没有任何意识连接。但在那一瞬间，当我向她展示深红色的阴影，那种用于休克和失落的深红色，并转向黄色以帮助缓解恐惧和压倒感时，她的恐惧消失了。
And it was just so mind-blowing. And the whole class, all of those therapists were like, wow, this is just great. sometimes it happens that quickly well and so i was doing mdr and that led me to brain spotting and before i was doing mdr i was doing kind of like somatic and parts-based therapies and sort of like some hypnosis techniques but mostly um just i wasn't trained in semantic experience or anything but just those kind of parts-based semantic styles and so i was always like looking not at what somebody's saying but what they're feeling and not what they think caused the event but like all these emotions associated with the event because a lot of times that it gets you either deeper
她现在正在接受培训。她是一名治疗师。她说：“我不害怕了。”所以我们甚至想到了她最后一次害怕黑暗的时候，就像检查一下。我们做了一个未来练习，当你今晚想到在黑暗中时，她的恐惧消失了。她说，她感到了快乐。她说：“我不敢相信我竟然在说这个。我感到快乐。我有点兴奋。今晚天会黑的。”
into it or to another thing. I was always trying to look at like what are the deep kind of subcortical brains motivations here that we're not always quite aware of. And I don't think that you can analyze that or interpret at least maybe I'm just missing a gene or not not bright enough to be able to tell you exactly, you know, what happened in childhood. I think you just have to make room for it until it kind of naturally comes up and that people will make those connections given kind of the space and the redirection. back to what they seem to be running from or towards.
这太令人震惊了。整个班级，所有的治疗师都说：“哇，这太棒了。”有时它发生得那么快。嗯，所以我当时在做EMDR，那引导我走向了脑点疗法，而在做EMDR之前，我做的是躯体和部分导向疗法，以及一些催眠技术，但主要是……嗯，我没有受过躯体体验的培训，只是那些部分导向的躯体风格，所以我总是关注的不是某人说了什么，而是他们感觉到了什么，不是他们认为是什么导致了事件，而是与事件相关的所有情绪，因为很多时候这会让你更深入
And so when I said on our podcast all the time, because, I mean, remember, we were the first people in Alabama that I was able to find that we're doing brain spawning. They were like, one person I tried to get the brain spawning with her, and she was like, oh, I got that training. I put it on psychology day, but I don't like it. And another person, yeah, anyway, there just wasn't anyone around.
地进入它，或者进入另一件事。我总是试图寻找那些深层的皮层下大脑动机，我们并不总是完全意识到。我不认为你可以分析或解释它，也许我只是缺少一个基因，或者不够聪明，无法确切地告诉你，你知道，童年发生了什么。我认为你只需要为它腾出空间，直到它自然地浮现出来，人们在给予空间和重定向后会建立这些联系。回到他们似乎在逃避或追求的东西。
Everybody acted like it was voodoo. Even the MDR people, which, you know, research, The clinical researchers don't always love EMDR because it doesn't work for, it's not as generalizable as some things, even though it does work for what it works for. And I kept saying on the podcast, like if you are a trauma patient where you're a therapist and you're desperate to help people and you've done lots of things and you can compare these and there's a new thing out there, send it to me. Don't tell me, well, my PhD advisor told me DVDT works for everything. So you should get DVT trained. Don't send me that email. But if you can say,
所以我一直在我们的播客上说，因为，记住，我们是阿拉巴马州第一批我能找到的做脑点疗法的人。他们就像，有一个人我试图让她做脑点疗法，她说：“哦，我接受过那个培训。我把它放在心理学日上了，但我不喜欢它。”还有另一个人，是的，无论如何，周围根本没有人。
well, I think lifespan integration plays with the precunious in like our relationship to the salience of time around events, but I think EMDR does it cute, you know, if you can kind of Venn diagram these and you found a new thing,
每个人都表现得好像它是巫术。即使是EMDR的人，你知道，研究，临床研究人员并不总是喜欢EMDR，因为它对……它不像某些东西那样具有普遍性，尽管它对它有效的东西确实有效。我一直在播客上说，如果你是一名创伤患者，或者你是一名治疗师，你渴望帮助人们，你做过很多事情，你可以比较这些，而且有一个新东西，发给我。不要告诉我：“嗯，我的博士导师告诉我DBT对一切都有效。所以你应该接受DBT培训。”不要给我发那封邮件。但如果你能说，
tell me, please tell me. And so I kept hearing about ETT from people. And I would look it up and the website doesn't have a ton of details and it's like, what is this? Like, is it a talk therapy?
“嗯，我认为寿命整合（Lifespan Integration）利用了楔前叶，关于我们与事件时间显著性的关系，但我认为EMDR做得很好。”你知道，如果你能用维恩图把这些画出来，并且你发现了一个新东西，
Like, I don't, and then, you know, I talked to some providers that were kind of almost like reticent to talk about the techniques. And there was like, well, you look at this board and there's color on it
请告诉我，请告诉我。所以我一直从人们那里听到关于ETT的消息。我会去查它，网站上没有太多的细节，就像：“这是什么？它是一种谈话疗法吗？”
And the people seemed incredibly smart. They seemed passionate about what they did. I was kind of doing everything I know to do to kind of bullshit to, you know, people that are looking for false positives and confirmation bias, or they're just kind of like doing a purple hat therapy. I mean, pretty credulous.
就像，我不知道，然后，你知道，我和一些对谈论这些技术几乎有些沉默寡言的提供者交谈。就像：“嗯，你看着这个板子，上面有颜色。”
And they seemed like, I mean, I couldn't kind of find any place where they seemed off. So I went and Vasquez is going on about light and color. And I'm just sitting there in Austin being like, why did I pay all this money? am I here? And the same thing that you described, like, somebody was going up. And I was like, I volunteer for this because I just, I don't, I don't believe whatever. And, and I'm like sitting in
人们看起来非常聪明。他们对所做的事情充满热情。我当时正在尽我所知地做所有事情来……你知道，对那些寻找假阳性和确认偏误的人，或者他们只是在做一种“紫帽子疗法”。我的意思是，相当轻信。
front of the board and, you know, the color yellow just would go black before my eyes. And I like, I couldn't. I was like, is this laser cut or, you know, what's, yeah, like, and I would touch it. And Vasquez was like, please, please, I ask you not to touch the board. They're $500. And I, but I couldn't understand why the color was going away. You know, it just the same, the same thing that so many people have had where it's like we can't believe it's going to happen until it happens. And even after the training, I mean, the training was pretty impactful and interesting that you buy all these things and I'm back in my office and I'm kind of trying to play with them. But I'm looking at, you know, the ETT One manual that has like, this is what
他们看起来像，我的意思是，我找不到任何他们看起来不对劲的地方。所以我去了，瓦斯奎兹正在谈论光和颜色。我只是坐在奥斯汀，心想：“我为什么要付这么多钱？我在这里干什么？”和你描述的一样，有人上去了。我说：“我自愿参加这个，因为我只是……我不相信任何东西。”然后，我坐在
is going on when there's a primitive parasympathetic response on the color. This is what's going on when there's a parasympathetic response. This is when there's a sympathetic. This is when there is no issue with the color at all. And like, and I have these charts for every single color and I'm just pointing my, because I use the brain spotting pointer to point in the board, which works better for me because then I know exactly where they're looking even if they don't see the color the same way I see it. So I just tap where I want them to look. And I'm looking at these charts that the patients obviously don't have and they're telling me the exact same thing and it's changing from this one to this one to this one to this one. And after two weeks,
板子前，你知道，黄色在我眼前变成了黑色。我当时想：“这是激光切割的吗？或者，你知道，是什么？”是的，就像，我会去摸它。瓦斯奎兹说：“请，请，我请求你不要摸板子。它们要500美元。”但我无法理解为什么颜色会消失。你知道，这只是……和很多人经历的一样，就像我们无法相信它会发生，直到它发生。即使在培训之后，我的意思是，培训非常有影响力且有趣，你买了所有这些东西，我回到办公室，我试图玩弄它们。但我看着，你知道，ETT一级手册，上面写着：“当颜色上有原始副交感神经反应时，这是怎么回事。当有副交感神经反应时，这是怎么回事。这是交感神经反应时。这是颜色完全没有问题时。”而且，你知道，我为每一种颜色都有这些图表，我只是指着我的……因为我使用脑点疗法的指针来指板子，这对我来说效果更好，因为这样我就能确切地知道他们在看哪里，即使他们看到的颜色和我看到的不一样。所以我只是点击我想让他们看的地方。我看着这些患者显然没有的图表，他们告诉我的完全一样，而且它从这个变成那个，再变成那个，再变成那个。两周后，
it was like, okay, well, I shoot, like I can't talk myself out of this because I'm sitting here with information that you don't have and I'm independently reproducing it. And I can't And it doesn't stop happening. But even back in Alabama, it was probably three, four weeks before I finally was just like, okay, like I, this neurologically is reproducible because I'm trying everything that I can to try and suggest something else to try and get it to not work like it's supposed to because I'm doubtful. I don't like authority. I don't like, you know, when somebody says these are the rules, I'm like, well, do they have to be? And I like, I couldn't make it not work, which was pretty wild. Joel was I think it was level two
就像：“好吧，好吧，该死，我无法说服自己不相信这个，因为我手里有你没有的信息，而且我正在独立地复制它。”而且它不会停止发生。但即使在阿拉巴马州，大概过了三、四周，我终于只是想：“好吧，这在神经学上是可复制的，因为我正在尝试我能做的一切来试图暗示别的东西，试图让它不像预期的那样工作，因为我很怀疑。我不喜欢权威。我不喜欢，你知道，当有人说这些是规则时，我会想，嗯，它们必须是吗？而且我……我无法让它不起作用，这太疯狂了。”乔尔，我想那是二级
when you came in and you've been sick and Yeah even then I had some doubt well yeah because I had a horrible ear infection and my eardrum had ruptured and so when y'all were like oh get the glasses we'll do the goggles for him it works for chronic pain I was like guys there's blood dripping out of my ear this morning
当你进来的时候，你生病了。是的，即使那样我也有一些怀疑。嗯，是的，因为我得了严重的耳部感染，耳膜破裂了，所以当你们说：“哦，拿上眼镜，我们给他戴上护目镜，它对慢性疼痛有效。”我当时想：“伙计们，我今天早上耳朵里还在滴血。”
Like, I didn't mom issues my way into the light. And yet, when the light position is here, my ear is a five alarm fire. And when the light position is here, it's gone on. And I was like, no, you know, ears are weird. Some juice probably moved around. And then you're clicking the thing. And it's like every single time, three o'clock was a five alarm fire. Six o'clock felt nothing.
就像，我没有通过“妈妈问题”进入光疗。然而，当光的位置在这里时，我的耳朵就像五级火灾。当光的位置在这里时，它就消失了。我当时想：“不，你知道，耳朵很奇怪。可能是一些液体移动了。”然后你点击那个东西。就像每一次，三点钟方向是五级火灾。六点钟方向什么感觉都没有。
We changed the direction of which light entered your eyes. And you felt differently depending on. What angle of the light came in here? I remember working with you and it was really exciting because I knew you, you are a scientist in many ways. You are skeptical. You want data. You want to understand. And so I thought, if Joel can experience the goggles, he's hell, it's a felt experience, right?
我们改变了光进入你眼睛的方向。你感觉不同，取决于光从什么角度射入这里？我记得和你一起工作，这真的很令人兴奋，因为我了解你，你在很多方面都是一名科学家。你很怀疑。你想要数据。你想要理解。所以我认为，如果乔尔能体验护目镜，他……这是一种触觉体验，对吧？
And I knew. I just had that confidence, this will work. and so I remember being really excited with you when the symptoms decreased and some of them went away and you were able to sit through the weekend and I remember we kept checking in with you like how do you feel Joel it did work I've had those those my whole life they're pretty rough and I wasn't able to get to a doctor
我知道。我只是有那种信心，这会起作用。所以我记得当你症状减轻，有些消失，你能够坐完整个周末时，我为你感到非常兴奋。我记得我们一直在询问你：“乔尔，你感觉怎么样？”它确实有效。我一生都有那些症状，它们非常严重，我无法去看医生，
anything because I was I had paid for the training I couldn't miss it there all day well so can you um say little bit for people that are like, okay, there's a light color, miracle, box, devised goggles, whatever, that heal people. How do I plug that into my clinical practice? This doesn't sound like me because I'm just a normal talk therapist. I mean, you were kind of coming from a cognitive and Rogerian world and then you had real specific trainings around, you know, the sex and different things, but just the kind of nuts and bolts of somebody comes in and
因为我付了培训费，我不能错过，他们整天都在。那么，你能为那些说：“好吧，有一个光、颜色、奇迹、盒子、设计的护目镜，无论什么，能治愈人。我该如何把它插入我的临床实践中？”的人说一点吗？这听起来不像我，因为我只是一个普通的谈话治疗师。我的意思是，你当时来自认知和罗杰斯的世界，然后你围绕性等不同事物进行了真正具体的培训，但只是关于某人进来，
they've got the same issue and you're talking about it. I know you've even got some marriage counseling demos that you did on the light device, which are kind of interesting, I don't do marriage counseling. But could you just kind of walk through how MJ is a talk therapist who does talk therapy and then now you've got these new toys? How do you kind of plug those into the things that other people listen to this may do? I would say prior to ETT and my focus was CBT and definitely Rosary. I remember, you know, meet clients. where they are, be with them. People want to want to be heard
他们有同样的问题，你在谈论它。我知道你甚至做过一些你在灯光设备上做的婚姻咨询演示，这很有趣，我不做婚姻咨询。但你能简单地讲一下MJ是如何作为一个做谈话疗法的谈话治疗师，然后现在你有了这些新玩具吗？你是如何把它们插入到其他人听这个节目可能做的事情中的？我会说在ETT之前，我的重点是CBT和罗杰斯。我记得，你知道，在客户所在的地方与他们会面，与他们在一起。人们想要被倾听
and understood, and the way to heal is through relationship and not being alone. So that was how I approached my practice. And people would talk about whatever was bringing them into the therapy room, whether it was an adjustment from one phase to another grief, trauma, a psychological condition.
和理解，治愈的方式是通过关系，而不是孤独。这就是我处理我的执业方式。人们会谈论任何带他们进入治疗室的事情，无论是从一个阶段到另一个阶段的调整、悲伤、创伤，还是心理疾病。
And talking just wasn't enough. When I learned how to do ETT, now there's a trifecta. My brain thinks, you client, knee therapist, ETT. Now, this is science, right? I can use the ETT. I can use the light and color to make the therapy more effective. And so transitioning from being just a talk therapist to now an ETT therapist was easier than I thought it was going to be. People would say, this is very weird.
而谈话是不够的。当我学会了如何做ETT，现在有了一个三位一体。我的大脑认为：你（客户）、我（治疗师）、ETT。现在，这是科学，对吧？我可以使用ETT。我可以使用光和颜色使治疗更有效。所以从仅仅是一名谈话治疗师转变为现在的一名ETT治疗师，比我想象的要容易。人们会说：“这太奇怪了。”
You want me to look at colors and talk about my feelings. I think that's really super strange. But I trust you, MJ, and I'm willing to try it. And once people experience that transition, the transformation and how they feel, they are drinking the Kool-Aid and it's easy. And my practice has been full for nine years. I don't even take, I don't have a wait list because I'm full all the time and I don't want to make people wait, but I will refer them. I need other, they need to keep training ATT therapist to, so I have more and more people. to refer to. And so when somebody comes in, Joel, and they say, I'll say, you know, let's do a check
你让我看着颜色，谈论我的感受。我觉得这真的很奇怪。但我信任你，MJ，我愿意尝试一下。一旦人们体验过那种转变、那种改变以及他们的感受，他们就会深信不疑，一切就变得简单了。我的诊所已经满员九年了。我甚至不接受预约，我没有候补名单，因为我一直都是满员的，我不想让人们等待，但我会把他们转介给别人。我需要其他人，他们需要继续培训ETT治疗师，这样我就有越来越多的人可以转介。所以当有人来找我时，乔尔，我会说，你知道，让我们先核对一下。
in. How are you feeling emotionally? How's your body feeling? What would you like to talk about today? And as they start talking, I will often say, is this something you would like to ETT to streamline our 50 minutes together, instead of you talking about this and then we ETT it, would you like to talk about it while we use the colors to help you feel better as we go? And once people have experienced ETT, yes, I have one lady who, she actually yelled at me, Joel. She said, never let me come here and not do ETT again. She said, I talked about all the things.
你的情绪感觉如何？你的身体感觉如何？今天你想谈些什么？当他们开始谈论时，我经常会说，这是否是你想要用ETT来简化我们50分钟会谈的内容？与其让你谈论这个，然后再进行ETT，不如我们在谈论的同时使用颜色来帮助你感觉更好？一旦人们体验过ETT，是的，我有一位女士，她甚至对我大喊大叫，乔尔。她说，永远不要让我来这里而不做ETT。她说，我谈论了所有的事情。
Time was up. I felt terrible because I had all this emotion and then I had to go, I had to leave. And she said, I know I'll feel better after I do ETT. So sometimes for new clients, there is a helping them understand we're going to do a scientific process. We're going to integrate light and color into what we're already doing to help you feel better before you leave. And now people consistently, Joel, they leave my office feeling better than what. they got there. If they didn't, I would not be a therapist or that wouldn't be a trauma therapist.
时间到了。我感觉很糟糕，因为我有这么多情绪，然后我不得不走，我不得不离开。她说，我知道做完ETT后我会感觉更好。所以有时对于新客户，需要帮助他们理解我们将要进行一个科学的过程。我们将把光和颜色融入到我们正在做的事情中，以帮助你在离开前感觉更好。现在人们总是这样，乔尔，他们离开我的办公室时感觉比刚来时好多了。如果不是这样，我就不会成为一名治疗师，或者就不会是一名创伤治疗师。
And I certainly wouldn't go around training therapists around the country if I didn't believe and know this science was replicable. I see new therapists who are scared. They're green. They feel like they don't know what they're doing. And I encourage them. This is science, right? You therapist or me therapist, you client.
如果我不相信并知道这门科学是可以复制的，我肯定不会到处去培训全国的治疗师。我看到一些新治疗师很害怕。他们很稚嫩。他们觉得不知道自己在做什么。我鼓励他们。这是科学，对吧？你是治疗师，我是治疗师，你是客户。
ETT, if we can integrate this and we do three things, another trifectal, have the client talk about their issue, they have to be connected to their emotions. So we're going to correct dissociation while showing them wavelengths of light that match their emotional content. What they feel changes. Science. It is replicable. Even the newest therapist can do this. Well, and in my mind, like when you're looking, because I'm, I'm, We're integrative. We wanted to get, you know, the cognitive therapy model of you go do CBT for six sessions. And if you don't have substantial improvement, then you need to take pills. You know, I saw that kind of waning. And there was a new trauma movement. And we wanted to have somatic experiencing. We wanted to have life spend integration. We wanted to have brain spotting. We wanted to have, you know, the QEG brain mapping. We wanted to have micronutrition. We wanted to have polyvagal stimulators. All the things that, you know, six years ago, now some of that's commercialized. But research was sort of indicated. it, that it was moving that way, you know, that stuff is always going to be more speculative because you can't randomize control trial, something that's very subjective or doesn't exist.
ETT，如果我们能整合这一点，我们做三件事，另一个三位一体，让客户谈论他们的问题，他们必须与自己的情绪连接。所以我们要纠正解离，同时向他们展示与他们情绪内容相匹配的光波长。他们的感受会改变。科学。它是可复制的。即使是最新的治疗师也能做到这一点。嗯，在我看来，当你观察时，因为我，我，我们是整合性的。我们想要得到，你知道，认知疗法模型，即你去做六次CBT。如果你没有实质性的改善，那么你需要吃药。你知道，我看到那种趋势在减弱。出现了一个新的创伤运动。我们想要有躯体体验。我们想要有生命跨度整合。我们想要有脑点定位。我们想要有，你知道，QEG脑图。我们想要有微量营养。我们想要有迷走神经刺激器。所有这些，你知道，六年前，现在其中一些已经商业化了。但研究表明，它正在朝着那个方向发展，你知道，那些东西总是更具推测性，因为你无法对非常主观或不存在的东西进行随机对照试验。
And then you need a couple of years to do that. But that's what I was seeing. And brain spotting was kind of the first thing. But so, I mean, I think the best models of therapy kind of do three things. And one, the first one is there's something that's immediately replicable. There's not 17 sessions of buy-in about like, oh, you don't believe it, but I promise if you do the work, this is going to happen, you can give somebody something in the room that day, you know, because you're sort of setting, even if
然后你需要几年时间来做这件事。但这就是我所看到的。脑点定位算是第一件事。但所以，我的意思是，我认为最好的治疗模型通常做三件事。第一，首先是有一些东西是立即可复制的。不需要17次会谈来建立信任，比如，哦，你不相信，但我保证如果你做了这项工作，这就会发生，你可以在那天就在房间里给某人一些东西，你知道，因为你是在设定，即使
the model's not terrible, the provider's not exploitive, you're kind of, I just think, 20 sessions in, you just got to have faith in me, but I'm not going to give you anything yet. You're sort of setting up something that is not a great, you know, power dynamic relationship. ETH definitely does the first one. I mean, the second thing is
这个模型并不糟糕，提供者并不剥削，你有点，我只是觉得，20次会谈后，你只需要信任我，但我还没打算给你任何东西。你是在建立一种不太好的，你知道，权力动态关系。ETT绝对做到了第一点。我的意思是，第二件事是
the models, I think, that are really good or kind of a universal language about emotion and how to engage with it. And so they integrate with any model, you know, like there's something that you don't, that, so somebody can come in to ETT as a cognitive behavioral therapist, as a DBT therapist, as a, experiencing therapist. Yeah, exactly. And you're talking about the same emotion, but just while you're talking about it, you say, okay, fine, you're saying you're not scared.
我认为那些真正好的模型是对情绪以及如何参与情绪有一种通用语言。所以它们可以与任何模型整合，你知道，就像有些东西你不需要，所以某人可以作为认知行为治疗师、DBT治疗师、体验治疗师进入ETT。是的，完全正确。你们谈论的是同样的情绪，但就在你谈论它的时候，你说，好吧，没关系，你说你不害怕。
kind of feels, see scared, whatever, maybe I'm wrong, let's get on the board, you know, and, you know, so, and which leads me to the third thing is that they're sort of empowering both to the patient and the provider. It's not like, oh, the provider has all this training and is on this tower and it's telling you how to do it and you have to look at the right thing. It's, the better models, I think, um, engage intuitively, the provider and the patient in a way that you can still indicate with research, but it doesn't start with a number, you know. And with the board, even people like, I was doing brain spotting before I felt comfortable treating with the board, but I would assess on the board, and people would
感觉，看到害怕，无论什么，也许我错了，让我们上板子，你知道，而且，你知道，所以，这引出了第三件事，那就是它们对病人和提供者都有赋能作用。并不是说，哦，提供者拥有所有这些培训，高高在上，告诉你该怎么做，你必须看正确的东西。我认为，更好的模型，嗯，以一种直观的方式让提供者和病人参与进来，你可以用研究来表明，但它不是从一个数字开始的，你知道。有了板子，即使是像我这样的人，我在感觉舒服地用板子治疗之前就在做脑点定位，但我会在板子上评估，人们会
go there and they'd see all of these distortions and the colors, and then they'd do brain spotting, and they come back and be like, I can, I can see green now. I can see green now. You know, I'm like, yeah, that's great. It went on crazy. That was going black for you for for two weeks, and now it's there, but we got working red. Red is having a problem. So it's like all of those things that I really look for in a modality that it's, it's universal enough. You don't have to learn all this weird language. You don't have to completely break your paradigm and and convert from one religion to the next one, that this is really just a faster way
去那里，他们会看到所有这些扭曲和颜色，然后他们会做脑点定位，他们回来后会说，我能，我现在能看到绿色了。我现在能看到绿色了。你知道，我说，是的，那太棒了。它并没有疯。它对你来说已经黑了两个星期了，现在它在那里，但我们开始处理红色了。红色有问题。所以就像我真正寻找的模态中的所有那些东西一样，它是足够通用的。你不必学习所有这些奇怪的语言。你不必完全打破你的范式并从一种宗教转换到另一种宗教，这实际上只是比你本来就在做的事情更快的方法。
of doing what you were doing anyway. You know, they're all present there for me. I have some therapist friends who are really experts in their field. One gentleman, Wayne Baker, he is an IFS therapist, and he's so good. He just loves IFS, and he also goes around with some trainers and trains other therapist and I of us. He is also an ETT therapist.
对我来说，它们都在那里。我有一些治疗师朋友，他们是各自领域的真正专家。一位先生，韦恩·贝克，他是一位IFS治疗师，他非常出色。他只是热爱IFS，他也和一些培训师一起去培训其他IFS治疗师。他也是一位ETT治疗师。
And these modalities just blends so well together. The parts of these language is even a part of the brain spawning training now. They've gone ahead and made part of it because you will dig these parts up with any of these things that are activating the subcortical brain that are brain-based, that just kind of skip all of the why I think that I'm here and go to why am I actually here. You're going to, you need to have parts-based language and semantic, you know, understanding of semantics. It's interesting with the, right, with ETT. We ask the person, we give them, have them talk about a topic, right?
这些模态融合得非常好。这些语言的部分甚至现在是脑点定位培训的一部分。他们已经继续并将其作为一部分，因为你会用任何这些激活皮层下大脑、基于大脑的东西挖掘出这些部分，这些东西只是跳过所有我为什么认为我在这里，直接去我为什么实际上在这里。你需要有基于部分的语言和语义，你知道，对语义的理解。这很有趣，对吧，用ETT。我们问那个人，我们给他们，让他们谈论一个话题，对吧？
And they tell us what they think. They access and kick up their emotions. And then we say, what do you notice you feel in your body? And that way, as we are changing the angle at which the color might come into their eyes, we can see at which angle do they have different sensations in their body, where does it feel better so that we can help them know, memorize the light that comes in at this angle, transpose to other angles to reduce any kind of emotional or physical distress. And so that blends in really this brain-based intervention, right, blends in really well with people who think in parts
他们告诉我们他们的想法。他们获取并激发他们的情绪。然后我们说，你注意到你的身体有什么感觉？通过这种方式，当我们改变光线进入他们眼睛的角度时，我们可以看到他们在哪个角度身体有不同的感觉，哪里感觉更好，这样我们就可以帮助他们知道，记住在这个角度进入的光线，转换到其他角度以减少任何形式的情绪或身体痛苦。所以这确实融合了这种基于大脑的干预，对吧，与那些以部分思考的人融合得非常好
and who do somatic experiencing in those body-based kinds of therapy modalities. Yeah, and I think another part of those what the best modalities do is like this one, I think, grows up with a provider. Like if you know nothing and have just taken your first class or you've done it for 20 years, it does scale. Because it's like when I started, you know, I was doing really good work and it was working. But I remember, you know, Vasquez coming in the second day and being like, okay, So everyone should have their colors memorized and every part of the brain they active in and everyone's kind of like and then you went around and we're like, no one has that done yet. No one ever does that. He always says that. You know, and then, you know, because it's such a new new thing and it's so technical. And then all of a sudden it becomes intuitive. It goes from being this scary detail or anything to this like, oh, I just get this. And I mean, it was like I sort of understood, okay, you know, orange is sort of ego and green is like anger, but it's also black hole sucking. It's going to show up an attachment disorder. or it's going to be burning in the chest, but it's kind of action and sometimes that shows up as anger.
以及那些在这些基于身体的治疗模态中进行躯体体验的人。是的，我认为这些最好的模态所做的另一部分是，我认为，与提供者一起成长。就像如果你什么都不知道，刚上了第一节课，或者你已经做了20年，它是可以扩展的。因为就像我刚开始的时候，你知道，我做得很好，而且它在起作用。但我记得，你知道，瓦斯奎兹第二天进来时说，好吧，所以每个人都应该记住他们的颜色以及他们激活的大脑的每个部分，每个人都有点，然后你走了一圈说，还没有人完成那个。从来没有人那样做。他总是那样说。你知道，然后，你知道，因为它是一个如此新的东西，而且它非常技术性。然后突然之间它变得直观了。它从这种可怕的细节或任何东西变成了这种，哦，我只是明白了。我的意思是，就像我有点理解了，好吧，你知道，橙色有点像自我，绿色就像愤怒，但它也是黑洞吸吮。它会出现在依恋障碍中。或者它会在胸口燃烧，但它是一种行动，有时表现为愤怒。
But I didn't have a great understanding until I'd done the board for about a year. And then it just became this natural thing of like, oh, orange is just self and how comfortable we are with this sort of center of identity. And so when orange is bleeding into red, that means that somebody mistook my emotional needs, or I mistook somebody else's emotional needs for conditions for my own survival, rightly or wrongly.
但我直到我用板子做了大约一年后才有了很好的理解。然后它就变成了这种自然的事情，哦，橙色只是自我，以及我们对这种身份中心的舒适程度。所以当橙色渗入红色时，这意味着有人误解了我的情感需求，或者我误解了别人的情感需求作为我生存的条件，无论对错。
You know, I, and, and yellow is trapped, controlled, paranoid boxed in constraints and green is kind of action and expansiveness, maybe anger. So yellow green is like in between those, like just confused and like I feel like something's hurting me, but I don't know what it is or I need to act, but I don't even know what action I want to do. You know, it's that space between, you know, anger and action and being boxed, you know, and then all of a sudden I was talking about this to patients, but it was, it just, you know, you kind of. have to start to feel how these things work and you have to watch you have to get comfortable with like okay green's in the chest but when i when that pops maybe it's going to hop up into blue or blue green and now the person needs to say something they need to verbalize something that they haven't done or maybe they're going to internalize it and it's going to hop down into yellow and it's going to be in their gut you know and you just get used to these patterns but you don't have to be the the master
你知道，我，而且，黄色是被困、被控制、偏执、被限制，绿色是一种行动和扩张，也许是愤怒。所以黄绿色就像在两者之间，就像只是困惑，就像我觉得有什么东西在伤害我，但我不知道那是什么，或者我需要采取行动，但我甚至不知道我想采取什么行动。你知道，那是愤怒和行动与被限制之间的空间，你知道，然后突然之间我正在和病人谈论这个，但它，它只是，你知道，你有点必须开始感受这些东西是如何工作的，你必须观察，你必须习惯于，好吧，绿色在胸口，但当那个弹出时，也许它会跳进蓝色或蓝绿色，现在那个人需要说些什么，他们需要表达一些他们还没有做的事情，或者也许他们会内化它，它会跳进黄色，它会在他们的肠子里，你知道，你只是习惯了这些模式，但你不必成为大师
that they i mean i you're effective as an eTP for brighter after the first training but then you could take a hundred more classes and you're still going to be you know getting familiarity with it and i think some of the better models are able to do that i hope that makes sense well as you're saying that i was thinking you are you're validating the therapist in the room right all therapy i think is intuitive right we we are in the room and we trust our gut instinct right and we listen to ourselves or mirror neurons, right? We feel what the client feels. One of the things I love about ETT is that now it's the therapist, even in the virtual room, right?
那个，我的意思是，你在第一次培训后作为ETP是有效的，但之后你可以再上一百节课，你仍然会，你知道，熟悉它，我认为一些更好的模型能够做到这一点，我希望这有意义。嗯，当你这么说的时候，我在想你是在验证房间里的治疗师，对吧？我认为所有的治疗都是直观的，对吧？我们我们在房间里，我们相信我们的直觉，对吧？我们倾听我们自己或镜像神经元，对吧？我们感受客户所感受到的。我喜欢ETT的一点是，现在是治疗师，即使在虚拟房间里，对吧？
ETT can be done virtually. So we have a remote light device. So there's a way for clients to log into a website, the counselor, the ETT therapist, logs into the website, We have a logging code. Each therapist has their own. And so now we can do the light device with people over the internet. They can use their phone, their iPad, their computer. But here's the thing.
ETT可以在虚拟环境中完成。所以我们有一个远程光设备。所以有一种方法可以让客户登录网站，咨询师，ETT治疗师，登录网站，我们有一个登录代码。每个治疗师都有自己的。所以现在我们可以通过互联网与人们一起使用光设备。他们可以使用他们的手机、iPad、电脑。但关键是。
We can, because it's science, you know this, Joel. Parfato. verbalization, emoting, visual eye stimulation. So I can talk to somebody on the phone. and I can have them use a color out, and I can direct them which colors to look at while they are talking to me about the topic. I remember the very first time I ETTed myself. This story, it still blows my mind.
我们可以，因为它是科学，你知道这一点，乔尔。言语化、情绪表达、视觉眼球刺激。所以我可以在电话里和某人交谈。我可以让他们使用颜色，我可以指导他们在和我谈论这个话题时看哪些颜色。我记得我第一次对自己进行ETT的时候。这个故事，它仍然让我感到震惊。
I did the ETT level one training, and that's where we learned how to use the spectral chart and the multidimensional eye movement, which are the sticks, the ones with the color at the end. And a brand new therapist, I don't really know what I'm doing. I started on Monday. It was working with my clients, even though I wasn't really sure what I was doing because I've just gotten trained. And so not long after that, I flew to Florida. And as I was on my way home on the flight, I was on the Southwest flight, the seats are a shade of indigo. That matters, but it didn't register to me at first. So I had some kind of a. sinus infection and my ears hurt so as we took off out of fort lauderdale and just the pressure in my head
我参加了ETT一级培训，那是我们学习如何使用光谱图和多维眼球运动的地方，也就是棍子，末端有颜色的那些。作为一个全新的治疗师，我真的不知道我在做什么。我周一开始。它对我的客户有效，即使我不确定我在做什么，因为我刚受过培训。所以在那之后不久，我飞往佛罗里达。当我在回家的航班上时，我乘坐的是西南航空的航班，座位是靛蓝色的。这很重要，但我起初并没有注意到。所以我得了某种鼻窦感染，我的耳朵很痛，所以当我们从劳德代尔堡起飞时，头部的压力
hurt so much and as we were flying i could just feel it and i was starting to panic because i knew as we were coming into austin it was really going to hurt on the way down and i was getting distressed and it hurts so much and i i had been looking at the back of the seat in front of me thinking about how what i was feeling in my body and noticing how upset I was and my eyes drifted to the seat um diagonally from me the back of the seat diagonally from me and I just you know just kind of mindlessly looked that way um and then I heard you know could hear myself saying oh my gosh you know my my ears are bothering me and um and then I had an awareness of yeah I do feel something but I don't feel as worried and anxious over here. And all of a sudden I realized I was looking at the color
非常痛，当我们飞行时，我能感觉到它，我开始恐慌，因为我知道当我们进入奥斯汀时，在下降过程中会非常痛，我感到很痛苦，它非常痛，我一直在看我前面的椅背，思考我在身体里的感受，并注意到我有多么不安，我的眼睛飘向了斜对面的座位，嗯，斜对面的椅背，我只是，你知道，只是漫不经心地看向那边，嗯，然后我听到，你知道，能听到自己说，哦，天哪，你知道，我的耳朵在困扰我，嗯，然后我意识到，是的，我确实感觉到了什么，但我在这里没有那么担心和焦虑。突然之间，我意识到我正在看颜色
indigo. And when I had looked at it, when it was coming in my eyes straight ahead, I felt one degree of distress when I looked to the right at indigo. And also the indigo from the seat in front of me is now coming in my eyes at the angle. I realized it felt better over there. And I realized I was Z-T-Ting myself. So I looked at the seat, the back of the seat to the left side of me. And what do I feel? How do I feel emotionally about what I feel? And then I memorized what I was seeing on the side that felt better. I looked to the other side. I tried to imagine I was seeing that same shade of indigo. My distress lightened. And when we landed, my head did not hurt. My sinuses had cleared up some. I didn't have the same emotional distress.
靛蓝色。当我看着它时，当它直直地进入我的眼睛时，我感到一种程度的痛苦，当我向右看靛蓝色时。而且前面座位上的靛蓝色现在正以这个角度进入我的眼睛。我意识到在那边感觉更好。我意识到我正在对自己进行ETT。所以我看了看左边的椅背。我感觉到了什么？我对我的感受有什么情绪？然后我记住了我在感觉更好的那一侧看到的东西。我看向另一侧。我试着想象我看到了同样深浅的靛蓝色。我的痛苦减轻了。当我们着陆时，我的头不痛了。我的鼻窦已经清理了一些。我没有同样的情绪困扰。
And now I was actually elated because I had ETTed myself on an airplane after just one training, not really even understanding the science at all, not really knowing what I was doing, but it worked. That was part. That was gas in the tank for me to go get more training. Well, I want to be respectful of your time. This is a great introduction to ETT for anyone unfamiliar. Hopefully Vasco can get more into the weeds with us about his theories and,
现在我实际上欣喜若狂，因为我在只接受了一次培训后，在飞机上对自己进行了ETT，甚至根本不了解科学，真的不知道自己在做什么，但它奏效了。那是其中的一部分。那是我去接受更多培训的动力。嗯，我想尊重你的时间。对于任何不熟悉的人来说，这是对ETT的一个很好的介绍。希望瓦斯奎兹能和我们一起深入探讨他的理论，以及
how you developed it and everything. Is there anything that you want to say or anything you want to include? And we'll definitely link to your practice website and the ETT website. I want to make sure that, you know, we name where therapists can go if they want to get trained in ETT. There's a website. It's www.etraining.com. And that website, it has articles about what ETT training is. And that website, it has articles about what ETT is. is. It talks about the science of how ETT works. It has a list of, there's a therapist directory. So there's a place you can go to find ETT therapists around the world, the ETT therapist in France and in Portugal. And we have somebody who's going over to train in Israel. Like we are expanding. Dr. Vasquez has trained therapist, I think he said 20 countries around the world.
你是如何开发它的等等。有什么你想说的或你想包括的吗？我们肯定会链接到你的诊所网站和ETT网站。我想确保，你知道，我们列出治疗师如果想接受ETT培训可以去哪里。有一个网站。是www.etraining.com。那个网站，它有关于ETT培训是什么的文章。那个网站，它有关于ETT是什么的文章。它谈论了ETT如何工作的科学。它有一个列表，有一个治疗师目录。所以有一个地方你可以去寻找世界各地的ETT治疗师，法国和葡萄牙的ETT治疗师。我们有人要去以色列接受培训。就像我们正在扩张一样。瓦斯奎兹博士已经培训了治疗师，我想他说是在世界各地20个国家。
You got any in Norway? A couple of people from Norway have emailed me and I hadn't been able to find anyone in their part of the, in the country. I don't know if there's any more. No, but I would love to go there and train some people. So they can go and sign up for classes. So if people, if therapists are interested in learning this training, experiencing level one, they can go find one. They can go find where the next level one class will be held and it goes through level seven. So it's the first two training classes are about how to use the four pieces of equipment, the chart and the MDM ones and the goggles and the light device.
你在挪威有吗？有几个来自挪威的人给我发了电子邮件，我没能在他们国家的那部分找到任何人。我不知道还有没有。不，但我很乐意去那里培训一些人。所以他们可以去报名参加课程。所以如果人们，如果治疗师有兴趣学习这个培训，体验一级，他们可以去寻找一个。他们可以去寻找下一次一级课程将在哪里举行，它一直到七级。所以前两个培训课程是关于如何使用四件设备，图表和MDM棍子，以及护目镜和光设备。
But then level three teaches protocols how to use ETT for trauma, depression, ADHD and ADD. OCD, right? It teaches how to correct dissociation. And then we have level four that talks about how to use ETT for physical conditions to reduce pain and change the stress and distress component tied to physical conditions. Level five talks about using ETT for spiritual issues. Six and seven are use ETT for addictions, which is very effective, and how to use this with couples. So they can learn all about what the classes are and sign up. Well, that sounds great. Thank you so much for your time, and we will definitely, I know, I have one question. Do you know if anyone that can do the remote ETT work,
但随后三级教授协议，如何将ETT用于创伤、抑郁、ADHD和ADD。OCD，对吧？它教授如何纠正解离。然后我们有四级，谈论如何将ETT用于身体状况，以减轻疼痛并改变与身体状况相关的压力和痛苦成分。五级谈论将ETT用于精神问题。六级和七级是使用ETT治疗成瘾，这非常有效，以及如何将其与夫妻一起使用。所以他们可以了解所有关于课程的内容并报名。嗯，听起来不错。非常感谢你的时间，我们肯定会，我知道，我有一个问题。你知道有人可以做远程ETT工作吗，
who is not behind a board that will not let them practice out, like, internationally? Like, because a lot of the social workers, even if they have board reciprocity and the LPCs, even if they have board reciprocity and can see somebody from California and Alabama or whatever, which I can't. My board doesn't do that. Like, I've had emails from Thailand. I've had emails from Iran. I've had emails from Norway, lots of places. And I, if there's a provider that's like a life coach or a chiropractor or a board that doesn't stop them from doing international practice, do you know anybody in the community that could do that? So this is a very legitimate question.
谁不是在板子后面，不会让他们在国际上执业？因为很多社会工作者，即使他们有板子互惠，LPC，即使他们有板子互惠，可以看来自加利福尼亚和阿拉巴马州或任何地方的人，但我不能。我的板子不那样做。就像，我收到过来自泰国的电子邮件。我收到过来自伊朗的电子邮件。我收到过来自挪威的电子邮件，很多地方。而且我，如果有一个提供者像生活教练或脊椎按摩师或板子不阻止他们进行国际执业，你认识社区里能做到这一点的人吗？所以这是一个非常合理的问题。
If we have a therapist who is, you know, counselors are limited by their state's rules, right, that we can only practice within the state that we are licensed in. now life coaches have the ability to practice across state lines so this is still a really gray area because we have to abide by our board rules so that we don't lose our license life coaches in and of themselves cannot become trained in ETT as of right now it's restricted to somebody who has a mental health license. So LPCs and LMFTs and LCSW PhDs, right? So we can get trained in this.
如果我们有一位治疗师，你知道，咨询师受到他们州规则的限制，对吧，我们只能在我们获得执照的州内执业。现在生活教练有能力跨州执业，所以这仍然是一个非常灰色的区域，因为我们必须遵守我们的板子规则，这样我们就不会失去我们的执照。生活教练本身目前还不能接受ETT培训，它仅限于拥有心理健康执照的人。所以LPC、LMFT和LCSW PhD，对吧？所以我们可以接受这个培训。
Life coaches cannot. I do know that, you know, it is effective remotely. So we need to work on that to make sure that we can we can provide it all over the world. Yeah. Well, we'll link to your website. We'll link to the ETT website where you can find information about trainings and all of that. And then is there anything else you want to add?
生活教练不能。我知道，你知道，它在远程是有效的。所以我们需要努力确保我们能够，我们可以在世界各地提供它。是的。嗯，我们会链接到你的网站。我们会链接到ETT网站，在那里你可以找到关于培训和所有这些的信息。然后还有什么你想补充的吗？
We really appreciate you joining us to help share it. Because I think that once, you know, I know some people that got trained in EMDR and were like, well, that's not for me or got trained in hypnosis or got trained in DBT and are just kind of like, I wish I had done that because I've never used that. I've not ever really met anybody who got an E. provider training and then said, I don't like that. And I've also never met anybody. And I mean, a lot of those people email me if I talk about any of this stuff.
我们非常感谢你加入我们来帮助分享它。因为我认为一旦，你知道，我知道有些人接受了EMDR培训，然后觉得，嗯，那不适合我，或者接受了催眠培训，或者接受了DBT培训，然后只是有点像，我希望我做了那个，因为我从来没有用过那个。我从来没有真正遇到过任何接受了ETT提供者培训然后说，我不喜欢它的人。我也从来没有遇到过任何人。我的意思是，很多人如果我谈论任何这些东西，他们会给我发电子邮件。
So if you have to get an email somebody that said, I did an ETT training and I don't use it and I don't like it. One of my one most profound moments, there's a lady who is very high up in the EMDR community, who is local to Austin. and she's been an EMDR practitioner since, you know, it began in the late 80s. She teaches EMDR and she came to the ETT training. I was in her level one class. I was co-teaching with Dr. Vasquez. And she was on the spectral chart and she decided that she wanted to ETT. when I think about not knowing about ETT before now.
所以如果你必须给某人发电子邮件，说，我参加了ETT培训，我不使用它，我也不喜欢它。我最深刻的时刻之一，有一位女士在EMDR社区地位很高，她是奥斯汀本地人。而且她自，你知道，它在80年代末开始以来一直是一名EMDR从业者。她教授EMDR，她来到了ETT培训。我在她的一级班里。我和瓦斯奎兹博士共同教学。她在光谱图上，她决定她想做ETT。当我想到在现在之前不知道ETT时。
She was moving through her grief because she devoted so many years to EMDR and then discovered this late in her practice that ETT was so effective. And she did move through her grief very quickly and came to a place of recognizing these skills integrate. it is good that she has skills from EMDR. She can use some of those skills in how she now does ETT with her clients. And she told me she doesn't actually use EMDR anymore. She is now an ETT therapist, which doesn't that speak to. There's still plenty of back and forth eye movements on UDT and different.
她正在经历她的悲伤，因为她为EMDR投入了这么多年的时间，然后在她的执业后期发现了ETT是如此有效。她确实很快地走出了她的悲伤，并认识到这些技能是整合的。她拥有EMDR的技能是件好事。她可以在她现在如何与客户进行ETT时使用其中一些技能。她告诉我她实际上不再使用EMDR了。她现在是一名ETT治疗师，这难道不说明问题吗？在UDT和不同方面仍然有大量的来回眼球运动。
Yes. Yeah. Well, thank you so much. I really appreciate your time. That's so kind to be to join us. And we will link to everything, MJ, in the show notes. So please click those links and check out her other stuff. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。是的。嗯，非常感谢。我真的很感谢你的时间。加入我们真是太好了。MJ，我们会在节目说明中链接到所有内容。所以请点击那些链接并查看她的其他东西。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。